hello folks yeah Badgers is doing the
show with us yeah she decided she was
gonna come settle the knife in my lap
while we were recording yeah well yeah
she is very spoiled so maybe you'll be
able to hear purring I'm not really sure
but so on this installment of the movie
retrospective we are finally finally
getting around to one of my very
favorite movies of the 1980s one of my
very favorite horror comedies that is
for goddamn sure and I can't believe
it's taken us this long to get to it
this is 1985
Fright Night yeah I hadn't seen this
movie in a long time I [ __ ] love this
it was a lot better it was a lot it's a
lot better than I remembered it and it
had a lot of character development and
the characters the themes were a lot
deeper than that I remember the writing
was good man writing was good from this
era oh yeah yeah well the cool thing
about this one now this was the
directorial debut of Tom Holland he
would go on to do child's play and many
other things prior to this he had been
an actor and then he had been a
screenwriter matter of fact he wrote the
screenplay for psycho 2 which was
actually way [ __ ] better than it had
any right to be he also had written the
screenplay for class of 1984 now when he
was getting into doing this and the one
thing one of the best things about this
movie among its many amazing qualities
is that you can tell that everyone
involved particularly Tom Holland was
like super super into this project
because there's just such there's such
an affection for the genre like on
display like and from everyone involved
that they really really wanted to make
this the best possible movie that they
could make it and it really really kind
of like shines through and like how
sweet and fun like an homage this is
because the thing about Fright Night is
that so Tom Holland got the idea he's
like I was just thinking about you know
just just to think about a high school
kid or a college kid whose neighbor is a
vampire nobody believes them and he's
like and I thought that would make a
really funny premise for a movie now it
should be noted that when this came out
in 1985
I mean horror movies I mean slashers
were like a big thing and so they even
kind of comment on that like inside
Fright Night where there's so much so
teenagers don't want to see vampires
anymore you know they want to see
teenagers getting you know or what do
you say like have hacking up young
virgins or something like that someone
to ski mask hacking up young virgins so
the interesting thing about this though
is that so it's kind of like a meta you
know just kind of a meta thing like on
the on the genre as a whole the vampire
genre like that old school like Hammer
horror type of thing like horror hosts
and stuff which in 1985 was kind of
pretty much going out of fashion oh yeah
it was kind of a throwback for its day
yeah but it's like so it was kind of
like a love letter to that but
interestingly when it came out and did
so well and got some got like a lot of
critical praise and it like made a lot
more money than they were expecting it
actually kind of kick-started like it
almost made vampires cool again you know
what I mean because like you know dead
NER dark came out Lost Boys came out and
it's almost like it reinvigorated the
vampire genre like for a new generation
I guess because at that point like I
said Hammer horror was in the 80s that
was like kind of creaky old like 60s
horror you know what I mean and it was
kind of cheesy and it was going out of
fashion a little bit I remember at the
time way the movie felt in terms of tone
was kind of like a cross between Salem's
Lot and kind of like a teenaged kind of
adventure movies wait felt at the time
but revisited and again there's a lot of
adult themes in it
yeah the undertones and stuff it there's
something there's like three tiers to it
there's young guys like 13 14 15
year-olds and then guys in their late
teens 18 19 and then there's old there's
an old guys story yeah so it's kind of
like showing three different groups of
guys at different developmental stages
yeah well there's also the adults too so
I guess you could say for yeah yeah
you're not I mean like the married
people yeah and the vampire know it in a
certain way with office kind of like it
but it just kind of showed guys and
different levels of the devout of
development yeah the whole thing you
notice that the
yeah yeah well the cool thing about it
like I said you know when Tom Holland
wrote the screenplay basically it was
just like you know what if your
next-door neighbor was a vampire and you
had to kill him and like you so I'm
killing people but no one would believe
you and he thought that would be like a
really funny you know for a horror
comedy like a very funny topic and like
I said he wanted to homage you know your
kind of horror hosts you know like
Svengoolie and you know Zachary and
Elvira and all that kind of stuff
because that was kind of going out of
fashion so with that he wrote the
character of because at first he just
had the kid yet Charley Brewster was
like his main character and he's like I
didn't know if I could make a whole
movie out of that but then he thought
well here's this kid who's super
obsessed with old horror movies and he
discovers that his next-door neighbor is
a vampire well who would I go to if I
was a teenager and was I would go to the
horror hosts the guy that was in all the
movies the vampire killer so then he's
like so then I decided to write that
character into it and from then the
movie just kind of wrote itself yeah so
he's even been quoted as saying that
Charley Brewster
you know the kid in this who's supposed
to be 17 or 18 years old he's still in
high school he's played by William
Ragsdale in the movie that he was like
the the engine that got the plot going
but that Peter Vincent played by Roddy
McDowall who was [ __ ] brilliant in
this that he was like the heart of the
movie which he really is because he has
like the biggest character arc you know
what I mean because at the beginning
he's just you know he's he's on this
like crappy
TV horror host he's on late at night
it's like he's showing all these old
cheesy ass movies that he was in like
when he was much younger he's actually
much younger and he was much younger in
real life than he looks in this movie
they made him look much older yeah they
got his hair grayed out
yeah they got his hair grayed and then
they them on stuff in the HD versions of
the movie you could see it but you
couldn't see it in the VHS yeah you know
you couldn't see that it was fake white
paint in the hair yeah but it's pretty
obvious in HD yeah cuz like I said they
wanted him to play like an old washed-up
yeah like horror actor who wasn't even
that good back in his day he was just
like in this cheesy like hey like Hammer
knockoff [ __ ] right and then he's just
like at
this [ __ ] little local station like
showing all these old movies in the
middle of the night yeah and the theme
there I'll tell you it wasn't real
obvious to me at the time and it wasn't
really spelled out in the movie but you
got this old British actor who's at the
end of his career and in the movies he
plays this badness like real brave of
Van Helsing style vampire killer but in
real life he's kind of this old British
queen and a coward you know and he
didn't believe in any vampires but there
was a lot of character development in it
ya know
after he realized that or was convinced
that vampires did exist
he becomes the man that he pretended to
be you know real heroic figure and it's
not really spelled out that way well I
guess it is the movie wasn't promoted
with that angle you have to see it to
see what it is you're talking about
nowadays they probably would have made
that the central focus of the movie but
they didn't make a big deal out of it
back then just dude became that the man
that he always wanted to be himself
actualized even though interestingly
when Tom Holland wrote the screenplay I
mean he obviously wrote the character of
Peter Vincent that was based on Peter
Cushing and Vincent Price and actually
he wanted Vincent Price for the role but
I've heard two stories there's either
like Vincent Price was like I don't
really want to do horror anymore or he
was too sick to you know he was his
health was too poor until it was a
Vincent Price but when Roddy McDowall
got the role yeah he said that he
modeled his performance after Bert Lahr
the Cowardly Lion in The Wizard of Oz
he's like that's what I wanted
that's what I wanted his like character
arc to be like that's what I wanted to
act like because he is like a super
super hammy like over-the-top act he's
not even British he's just like kind of
like affecting that is pertaining to
Bieber yeah look that's what I mean so
he was kind of like cuz you could I mean
he's obviously not you know so I mean so
that you know they got the kid I thought
the actor was supposed to be British
well he just like put on that
affectation like I said because you know
how a lot of like is he
actor he was one of those old-school
like actor trying to accept like I said
he knew he wasn't any good and he's even
said that in interviews that he's like
he's supposed to be like a washed-up
shitty actor back in the old days who
thought he was awesome okay and then now
he's like super you know now he's like
at this shitty [ __ ] TV TV station
right that makes that adds another yeah
it's into it that I didn't know I
thought he was actually supposed to be a
British character no he was he was he
was a washed-up American actor
pretending to be British yeah he was
just trying to be yeah it was like that
all right that makes it even more that's
what I mean that's what's so [ __ ]
great about this movie you guys if you
haven't seen it seriously this is easily
easily one of the best one if not the
best horror comedies of the 80s it's
just like I said it's just such an
affectionate homage to that genre and so
the whole premise of the story like I
said you know Charley Brewster is this
kid he lives with his single mom he's
got a girlfriend he's played by Amanda
burse who obviously became famous later
on for being the neighbor on married
with children Marcy Darcy she was
actually 27 and this even though she was
supposed to be a high school kid but she
still pulled it off I thought William
Ragsdale was 24 I looked it up cuz wit
cuz we were saying all these all these
movies with like all these kids playing
high school students and they were all
in their 20s they were but um so he's
got this girlfriend and her name is Amy
and they fit this made us laugh and this
made Tom laugh but they've been going
out for a year and Amy still has not put
out yeah I call [ __ ] on that and I
saw it I said no I was I've been to high
school at least once didn't go down that
way well I don't think it would go down
that way now it is either yeah a week
was an eternity you can still get away
with that like maybe in the 8th why you
holding out on me two weeks yeah right
so it's like yeah in a way like I I get
where she was coming from cuz she was
like she wasn't sure about it and she
was like kind of scared she was a virgin
and all this other kind of stuff and he
was actually pretty understanding about
it although he was you
understandably getting frustrated so
finally they're at the house one night
like making out upstairs while mom is
downstairs and she's finally like okay
we're going on with that we're going
ahead with the sex that's fine yeah and
then he gets distracted by two guys out
in the yard carrying a coffin into the
neighbor's house like someone's moving
into the house next door and he's like
there's two guys enter the coffin and
he's like and then she's like and then
he just like completely ignores her
she's sitting there with her bra and
everything like that gee all right [ __ ]
you buddy
yeah like having this fight through the
whole thing
so now at first like I said because
Charlie it's just kind of like obsessed
with horror movies especially old horror
movies like Peter Benton is this hero
and he loves like all these old you know
old movies so he just thinks it's kind
of weird and stuff so he kind of starts
spying on the guy next door especially
after the next day when they get a
[ __ ] when a call girl shows up yeah
at the house next door and she's like oh
is this okay well I'm gonna go over here
yeah so alright so Charlie's looking out
the window that night because he see it
he saw the car call girl go in there and
he's hoping to see some action um what
protip to vampires out there though if
you don't want to get caught for serial
murder close your shades man because
like your neighbors are like watching
you through the binoculars so he's
looking at the window through the
binoculars and he's got like his snacks
and like you know porn magazines on the
ground and stuff like that and he sees
his neighbor this suave [ __ ]
named jerry dandrige who's played by
Chris Sarandon he actually sees little
fangs come out and he's got like big
long nails and stuff and it looks like
he's gonna bite this one in the neck
then later on he notices that someone is
bringing a body or what appears to be a
body wrapped in that black plastic out
and puts it into the back of a car now
he thinks it's weird but he doesn't
really like get super serious about
until the next day when he's at school
because then he sees like a news report
that the call girl there's a picture of
her on the news and flicked that she was
found I think she would sound like
beheaded or something like that so he
starts to freak out and say okay
the neighbors a vampire is obviously
killing people and so he tries to tell
Amy and his best friend he's played by
Stephen Jeffrey's evil Edie he was like
another big horror nerd and who was
really great in this he's like super
funny and so he tries to sell them
obviously they don't believe him but
he's like look I did see that girl over
there it's like I'm not gonna tell the
cops he's a vampire I'll just tell them
that I saw that girl over there and they
gotta investigate so the police come
over to the house and there's like this
whole thing that happens now in her it
happens to you that jerry dandrige his
character who is the vampire he also has
a quote-unquote roommate named Billy
Cole who I guess he's that's like his
daytime protector he's not human
either though no he's like a Thrall yeah
I think that's probably what it is
because I see a lot of people going oh
well he's not a vampire because he
walked her in the daytime he's like a
Renfield like you know like mr. Barlow's
yeah that's what I thought like he's he
can do human [ __ ] but he's not because I
think it's an rice influenced type stuff
where you know the main you dude wants
to become a vampire so he starts to
become the servant of a vampire he gets
some blood you know he gets some powers
but in the end that vampire is not gonna
turn him into a vampire he's just using
him yeah used him as a slave basically
yeah throw ice that happens in a lot of
vampire movie that's what I'm saying
because they need somebody to like watch
over him during the daytime so people
just don't bust and that comes from
renze Lemon [ __ ] out of a Renfield yeah
he had some vampire blood in him but
yeah because he didn't turn him into a
full BAM pyre he was just kind of like
his little their disposal helper yeah
yeah they're disposable slaves really
yeah so it so it so happens that the
cops come they obviously like interview
Billy Cole and he's just like oh what we
just you know I don't know what you're
talking about and the cops and then like
Charley like flips out and starts
telling the cops oh it's you have to go
down to the basement they have coffins
down there and Jerry dancers is a
vampire so obviously the cops are like
yeah [ __ ] off kid and they don't believe
him
so then he decides that he is going to
go contact Peter Vincent the great
vampire killer who is on TV and who is
in all these old movies yeah
obviously and it so happens that the day
he goes to the studio till I talked to
Peter Vincent it's the same day he's
been fired from the show his like you
know late night show which is called
fright night because young people don't
want to see vampire movies anymore
especially the kind that he used to do
yeah so the most character shows up I
mean yeah I think a story gets
interesting when this character shows up
related Roddy McDowall brings a lot to
this movie and he loved this role yeah I
mean he really the role the role I
interpret I interpreted the role is that
he's a gay character and I I remember to
kind of like a bunch of gay undertones
with the movie too even between the
vampire and his thrall there were a lot
of people have pointed that out because
later on you know I don't want you we
don't want to spend tell the whole story
spoil the whole movie later on the
vampire betrays that thrall really that
thrall rises to the occasion willing to
give his life for his for his vampire it
looked like to me like some you know
trisexual [ __ ] going on yet I mean they
were bringing women in in a triad try
and [ __ ] out yet I mean he's got a
vampire his wanna be a vampire lover and
then these hookers that they're killing
and drinking yeah but it looked like
love triangle [ __ ] to me it did kind of
the only really direct reference they
make to that is where when jerry
dandrige and the what they called the
live-in carpenter when they first move
in next door Charlie's mom is like
looking out the window like talking
about how handsome jerry dandrige is
yeah and then she says oh but he's got a
live-in carpenter over there with my
luck he's probably gay yes she's single
and on the make man and then but he
comes over and like she you know he's
laying the term I mean Vincent is he
just comes off as a as a queen to me an
actor you know
cowardly but still a good guy and the
theme throughout the whole movie it's
not stated explicitly but this is how I
interpret it throughout the movie you
got the teenage guy trying to save his
teenage girlfriend but in many ways
Vincent is trying to save the young guy
being killed by it by these
vampires and it all works out good and
he you know he ends up being a hero and
that's just that was the theme that that
I picked up from it yeah you know I mean
I may be wrong but it's hard to ride him
in doubt doing this part he just comes
across as a gay actor yeah I mean he's
not married he's an older guy nothing's
ever brought up about his sexuality or
having a wife or anything but he's
definitely defending people yeah and it
he never makes a move on the kid it's
just that you know I mean you could tell
that he was very protective of everybody
really and it just comes across as to me
as a as a gay character yes but like I
said it could go either way
I think in the 80s they wouldn't spell
it out they'd leave it up to you yeah I
mean and that's that's how I interpret
it I mean most like I said most people
that talk about because a lot of people
have talked about this movie having a
gay subtext which a lot of movies in the
eighties did actually I'm not only one
to saw it um not not so much with
Vincent's character but more with the
vampire and like I said in his buddy
like that you know that was kind of like
a more we got a lot we got a lot of gays
subscribers if you Gayla watch that
movie and you get back with me yet you
tell me is that guy gay and I'm yeah I'm
telling you that that sounds like an 80s
gay character the way that character was
remade me so back in the 80s they didn't
they didn't push that to the forefront
they let you see it if he wanted to yeah
it's just that's how life interpreted
well I'm like I said I think that one
you can tell because Roddy McDowall
really really wanted this part and he
really really loved playing this
character and that really comes across
yeah he is like you said probably the
most interesting character in the movie
because he has the largest arc he's very
funny at the beginning like I said he
comes across very much like the Cowardly
Lion yeah um because he's an actor he's
the vampire killer in movies so he's
like very up himself he's very full of
himself but when like dangerous [ __ ]
really starts to happen his first
instinct is to like run and hide he
doesn't want anything to do with it um
you know to me because at first he
doesn't believe Charlie that the guy's a
vampire you know he tell us the kid to
[ __ ] off finally um you know Amy and
Evil Edie like come to him and he's just
like no that kids crazy it's like
there's no such thing as vampires and
they're like look you really have to
help
he's gonna kill the guy next door you
know while he's sleeping if you don't do
something and finally they offer to pay
him they're gonna give him like $500 if
he will come and perform a quote-unquote
vampire test on jerry dandrige in front
of Charlie so that Charlie will you know
yeah we'll be convinced that he is not a
vampire yeah and then the way the story
ends you got a guy who was a fake
basically an actor yeah okay a fake
vampire killer who's cowardly he's he's
queenly kind of effeminate you know that
mean he's gay he's not a sick setting
he's losing his job he's not a success
that character moves into a gay hero
really that's how I interpret it yeah he
was still gay but no he really was a
vampire killer he killed a bunch of him
in the movie how many campfires did he
actually kill include including the
thrall maybe four well no because well
he killed um I think you could procure
two three yeah - and then well because
they kind of him and Charlie both kind
of got together and killed because
they're the only aren't some people that
turned into vampires
no just evil way it's just evil ed okay
and he killed that was oh my god I have
to talk to you about he killed a vamp
two vampires in a Thrall yeah so that so
he killed multiple although Charlie
killed the thrall I think because he
remember he shot him a bunch of times
and it didn't do anything like he was in
on it that yeah yeah that was the first
one that they killed and that's really
where they yeah Vincent started to get
confidence that you can't fight ya
pirate type things yeah so that's what
that was the first part of his cuz it
from birth at first they thought Billy
Cole was just a guy right so he's so he
brought a gun and he's like wrong we can
just shoot him he's just a dude but then
he got back good by the end of it by the
end of Vincent story-arc
he's a successful hero and he gets his
show back yeah so so he actually becomes
the man he he wanted to be yeah which I
thought that was awesome that wasn't
yeah the one he always played and there
one the ones that he always played in
the movie that's what he really became
yeah and the the lesson was that my
interpretation having to come up in the
80s the subtext in the writing is that
again
man could be a hero how I interpreted it
yeah yeah like I said it's it you know
it could be interpreted that way you
could also interpret it like in a more
kind of universal way where it's just
like you know like I said he was just
like a cowardly character and he just
like I was looking at it from the 80s
Hollywood's perspective there are a lot
of gay people in Hollywood at that time
and that was the story that I believe
that they were showing yeah yeah you
know I mean I have to say too that the
special effects in this are amazing
particularly the special effects where
evil ed after he gets turned into a
vampire and he'd like a tax Peter
Vincent in a wolf form and then Peter
Vincent ends up like staking him with
like a sharp like a table leg and he
kind of like turns back into evil ed as
he's dying and it's like not only a
really awesome like special effects
scene but it's also like a really
effecting scene because Peter Vincent
you can tell that he feels really really
bad that he had to kill this little kid
you know he's not a little kid he's like
a teenager you know because he turned
into a vampire and you know just that
cold like the wolf's transformation like
cos he's going back into the you know
person and stuff like that is really
cool also I want to say too that when
amy gets vampa fied she is almost
unrecognizable like when they did cuz
you know they tried to make her look
very good girl she had like the shorter
hair yes like she's a little bit boyish
kind of and she wasn't very attractive
actually yeah she was attractive as a
vampire but not that's what I mean it
was like a huge upgrade yes
so like when she got vamp abide by Jerry
cuz she got kidnapped by him for a while
and you know he bit her and stuff and
she comes out and like this Marilyn
Monroe looking dress she's got this long
like red wild hair and she had it better
makeup yeah and it's like well the best
scene in this scene used to like just
kind of freaked me out when I was
younger is when you know when she's kind
of turns her face away from Charlie and
she's like you said he wasn't good you
wouldn't let him get me and then she
turns around and she has that huge
[ __ ] mouth was like all this [ __ ]
teeth in her mouth as a bunch of teeth
in it yeah and I was like it looked like
a big like snake face or something like
that it was just like really really cool
I have to say too that a lot of the
effects work I was there's a really good
it's not it was on shutter it's not on
there anymore but there was a three and
a half hour three and a half hour
documentary about the making of fright
night and it was called you're so cool
Brewster which if you've seen the movie
you'll know why it's called that and
they went into like exhaustive detail
about like the making of and all the
special effects and everything like that
and it's just you know they were talking
about the [ __ ] contact lenses which
you know now contact lenses they're just
like that thin plastic and it's like
super easy and so back then they were
made of like they were really thick
glass and they had to like buff them and
like get all the [ __ ] out of there and
they had some problems with you can only
wear them for 20 minutes at a time and
then they had to take them out because
you couldn't see through them you know
like those big yellow [ __ ] things
that they were but yeah so special
effects amazing I love the evil ed
character I've seen this movie probably
a million times I used out on VHS back
in the late 80s and it's it's just super
fun it's you know there's like some 80s
cheese like with the nightclub scene and
stuff like that but it actually had some
great songs in it too like they had won
by sparks the Jay geils Band did the
theme song like the title song and stuff
like that now here's something that was
really interesting I had completely
forgotten that they made a Fright Night
part 2 it came out in 1988 remember that
and I was thinking to myself it's like
okay I know I must have seen this at
some point but so I found it on YouTube
like kind of a shitty like old VHS copy
like pan and scan any good um it's
actually not bad I watch it the only um
the only recurring cast they got William
Ragsdale back as Charlie and they got um
Roddy McDowall back as okay but um it's
actually like because I'm watching it
and I was like I probably saw this
because every now and then like I'd see
a scene or like a line read or something
I'm like that seems familiar so I must
have seen this but I didn't remember
anything about it so I must have seen it
like one time I was the writing is good
um it was a different writer and a
different director um Tom Holland was
like on set and like he did like
consult on the script and stuff like
that it's not I mean it's a similar
pretty similar storyline it's like what
you get is you know Charlie's in college
now he has a different girlfriend
because Amanda verse didn't want to come
back for the second one so and and and
it's like you know he's in colleges in a
dorm and then basically there's a
vampire named Regine and she is you know
they reveal later on that she is the
sister of Gerri Dandridge and she's kind
of come looking for them because revenge
and she kind of has like a whole little
vampire posse now an interesting angle
that they did for the sequel to was that
at the beginning Charlie has been in
therapy and he has convinced himself
that vampires aren't real go through
that and that yeah and that the whole
thing like with jerry dandrige and
everything he's like oh well jerry
dandrige is just a regular old serial
killer and i imagine that he was a
vampire and stuff but Peter Vincent
still believes so there's kind of like a
conflict there where you know Jim to
remember like yeah where Charlie like
goes back to see him and he's just you
know well the first version the writing
is top-notch it is yeah you got that you
got the the normal you got the very
superficial story that happens and then
there's all these sub texts that are
there or maybe they're not there but
that's a sign of good writing to me they
they let you decide what it is that you
see outside that normal story arc which
I you know I mean like all the subtext
yeah about it to me that's always a sign
of good writing you gotta man oh definit
where you see the story you watch the
story you enjoy it but then you go wait
a minute was this going on was this
actually happening but the different
levels of it yeah you can read different
things into it that were always like
really good what like receipt was like
the death scene between evil Edie and
Vincent is there and you wave Vincent's
interaction with this you know dying
vampire what are we seeing there you
know I mean you know just a lot of a lot
of emotion going on yeah you know we
just seeing normal compassion or are we
seeing a gay subtext I don't know yeah
it's it's but that's that's what made
the movie cool it's on you to interpret
it you
and like I said I think it's it's
important to note too that like you know
Tom Holland you know he started as an
actor and then he went into
screenwriting and he like is actually
like has written like a lot of really
good movies prickly in the horror genre
so he knew what he was doing with it
like he's come at it from an actor's
point of view he comes at it from a
writer's point of view like I said this
was the first movie that he directed and
that's kind of amazing is this movie
yeah is I mean it's a cult classic yeah
not only they telling you the stories
now not only are all these subtext
there's also of morality tales happen in
between all this stuff and I like that
kind of [ __ ] I like things that are very
close to you know mythology yeah you
know Star Wars level tight early you
know we're talking about you know the
original Star Wars movie level yeah you
know uh mythologies you know which is
good stories with you know symbolism and
stuff and morality tales I'm into that
yeah this is one that this is a movie
that is like that well and plus this
movie is just fun and yeah it's just a
fun movie it's got like funny moments
it's got scary moments as good special
effects and stuff you can drink during
this movie yeah it's just like it's
awesome super super fun yeah if you can
pay attention to it and see all these
themes and all these lessons and you but
you don't have to [ __ ] you don't have to
take it that seriously yeah the tone of
the movie is kind of playful yeah so you
know I like that but even though like I
said it still got creepy kind of [ __ ]
going on but you know the character
jerry dandrige is very very good Chris
Sarandon plays a great [ __ ] vampire
even though he was initially reluctant
because he's like oh I don't really want
to do another horror movie even though
he went on to do child's play with Tom
Holland as well but you know what I mean
so it's just all the characters are good
they all work together really good yeah
um another thing too that I wanted to
mention and maybe the reason why this
works so well and why all the characters
interacted so well with one another was
that Tom Holland had the whole movie
pretty much storyboarded out like scene
for scene and he gave the all the actors
two weeks and they worked the whole
movie through like a stage play like
over and over yeah okay I can I can feel
it in the movie I can see that they did
it like that's why the movie has such a
good flow to it
yeah and because these characters had
been interacting with each other they
all had their own backstories that they
made up about the characters a lot
happens in this movie I forgot how much
actually happens in the movie it is and
it moves really really well paced yeah
moves along quickly and a lot of [ __ ]
happens for the story to unfold and
there's a lot there without it being
messy or tedious it's it's it's a good
movie it's a lot better than I
remembered it just goes to show you how
good the storytelling was of the
eighties it wasn't all good yeah there
was a lot of [ __ ] they do the dudes that
knew their [ __ ] back in the 80s could
tell you a badass story yeah and and no
matter what what who you were what your
politics were you could enjoy that story
and understand that message and under
either they were just real good at it oh
yeah and like I said one of the best
things and one of the things that keeps
me coming back to this movie is that you
can tell that Tom Holland who wrote it
he was really really he really loved
old-school horror he loved all those
cheesy Hammer movies he loved like all
this old horror hosts and stuff so he's
like having fun with that but he's not
making fun of it there's like let you
know what I mean there's it's very
affectionate I use it as so much kind of
using a similar template or a tonal
template well yeah
you just have to see it you have to see
it draw your own conclusions I think
it's a high quality movie it is like
what I'd like to see the sequel now no I
didn't know that there was it some yeah
I watched it a couple hours ago like
before we recorded this it's actually
not bad I had seen it back in the 80s
because I did remember a couple of
scenes but it hadn't made in an
aggression the same way though wait a
few weeks you've already seen it all
well I was I was only paying attention
to like the first half cousins mother
[ __ ] so we can I want to see in high
quality if I'm gonna see them you know
rent it yeah you should probably run it
but I'll tell you what Fright Night will
be in my blu-ray collection I will
eventually buy this yeah because like I
said I had this on VHS I probably seen
it at least 50 times if we want more we
also reach right after this we watched
Lost Boys and that one I also want to
own I forgot how good that was
that'll probably be the next review yeah
prime Majesty
oh and I have to mention too I haven't
seen it but in 2011 there was a remake
of Fright Night um I kind of want to see
it even though I read the Wikipedia plot
synopsis it's similar but they did a
couple different things with it David
Tennant actually plays the Peter Vincent
character and he's is not an old-school
horror host because they thought that
modern audiences wouldn't connect as
much with that being little do they know
yeah but I know but it's like said they
thought boy those donuts yeah they
thought that wouldn't work so they made
him like a Criss Angel type like Vegas
like I've watched a Vegas magician who
also happened to be a vampire expert for
whatever reason Colin Farrell plays the
jerry dandrige character it has like a
lot of good actors in it Anton Yelchin
who passed away you know he was in the
Star Trek movies and stuff like that
that younger kid he played the Charley
Brewster character will see it um but
I've heard that I think the people that
were in the original movie like they got
asked about it like a horror convention
and some of them said yeah it was all
right but it wasn't really in the same
spirit and at a particularly Steven
Jefferies who played evil ed in the
original one he thought well I didn't
really like the evil ed character in the
new one because he seemed a little
mean-spirited whereas in the original
movie he was just kind of a goofball and
I think in the remake - they made it
like Charley and evil ed weren't friends
anymore because Charley had like started
hanging out with like a cooler crowd and
like evil ed was like super dorky and he
didn't want to hang out with him anymore
so they had that kind of thing going on
which wasn't in the original I mean in
the original Charlie wasn't really a
dork he was just kind of like a regular
dude yeah you know what I mean and you
know evil ed was kind of dorky but
lovably dorky you don't have thing I
thought he was annoying he's a little
bit annoying yeah but you know he was
better as a vampire true well he was a
freaky vampire yeah with that hair so
yeah like that it's funny because he
actually wanted when he went to UM to
read for the part he actually wanted the
Charley Brewster role but then they
called it back and said no we want you
to be evil ed and he was kind of bummed
out and that's and he wouldn't he didn't
want to do the sequel even that he died
in the first one but you know they
thought they could bring him back but
what
oh I just forgot to mention that the
practical effects in this are really
strong yeah I mean I said that before
okay yeah they're very good there was
just something about CG that could ruin
this movie the the tone of the movie in
the time the setting and everything just
went yeah I heard the CG and the remake
was not yeah yeah I'm glad they didn't
have CG at this time because they would
have used it and it would have [ __ ]
read it would have been terrible yeah
because the way they worked with the
practical effects it kept the movie
totally was consistent throughout the
whole thing and it's a masterpiece of
what this movie is a masterpiece of what
it is yeah you know it's not you're not
talking with the shining or anything
like that it's just it's a Saturday
night movie yeah it's a fun comedy right
and it's it's doing its job really well
and it stood up to test it stood the
test of time if you ask me in my humble
opinion fifty years of [ __ ]
excellence I'm telling you movie the
movie holds up yeah it's brilliant it's
a brilliant movie and like I said it's
not only like kind of scary it's funny
yeah and it also has like a really
really good heart to it which a lot of
horror movies don't have it was that
time when Spielberg was still doing good
[ __ ] he still does the good stuff but
their 80s there's something about 80
Spielberg there's something about that
eighties middle-class America settings
where you have this [ __ ] tone you
know like Back to the Future it's just
like it's like that yeah it's like that
same kind of that same tone tonal place
to where it's kind of like a horror
movie version you can go back and watch
that movie and it takes you into that
time and evidently young people the
younger generations still like it you
know they like a lot of this 80 stuff
even then the new retro wave and stuff
that's coming out and all the to them
it's retro but they get it quality is
there you can watch these old movies and
go yeah that was a badass story yeah and
this is definitely one it's one like
that that stands out and like stands the
test of time like I said I haven't seen
the remake yet if you've seen it tell me
I've heard it wasn't terrible like it
got like pretty decent reviews and they
also made a sequel to that yes came out
in 2003
but I think it went direct-to-video so I
haven't seen that either our AMC
Theaters doing reruns of 80s and 70s
classics like alien yeah yeah and
they're putting up ghostbusters and they
do it only those nights are packed yeah
and they're packed with you know Gen Z
yeah you know so it's making a comeback
the the younger the younger audience
understands this tone it almost seems
like the 80s never went away like it's
yeah you know what I mean really in a
way the good things of the 80s kind of
have survived I mean there was a lot of
shitty stuff in a DC like it's gone but
yeah no one remembers this cuz it's just
kind of like what happens from every
decade like there's always a bunch of
[ __ ] that like nobody remembers yeah but
uh the good [ __ ] from the eighties like
it's still ya can live on it you know
like you just can't be Indiana Jones
wanting yeah that movie will just always
exist it will always that movie will
stand the test of time yeah you know
and same with Fright Night I mean yes
easily easily and you know what my
favorite the back to the back to the
futures some of the Eddie Eddie Murphy
movies you know Beverly Hills Cop yeah 1
& 2 will always to me will always be
great cop comedies yeah yeah hey yeah
and you know I have to say to you that
like speak in a fright night I really
really one of these days I was gonna do
it this year but I didn't think of it in
time I wanted to do the vampire ami
Halloween costume I could find a dress
like that but I need to do like old like
cast my date like I looked it up and cuz
I was curious to see if anyone had done
it and I did find two girls that had
done it and one girl did it just with
makeup and that looks pretty cool and
one girl like went whole hog and she
like you know made of latex cast of her
whole face and you know did that and
that looked pretty cool too but it
doesn't seem to be a very common
Halloween costume I mean as as well
known as Fright Night is and it was yeah
and particularly if you google Fright
Night I mean that's one of the first
pictures that comes up as a me with that
big [ __ ] mouth with all the teeth
sticking out of it yeah so you know and
that dress like with it's like I said
it's kind of like a halter dress that
looks sort of Marilyn
I wish so I don't know maybe I'll do
that one of these days
gotta get some yellow and red contact
lenses and a big old latex thank you
yeah yeah I could probably do that
pretty cheaply honestly but yeah if you
have not seen Fright Night from 1985
what the hell is the matter with you you
really really need to see it because
it's one of the best movies of the 80s
you know by any measure so you should
definitely check it out and then you
know the the sequels not bad either I've
heard the remakes okay but I haven't
seen it yet so I can't comment alright
so we will see you next time bye